allora iniziamo subito già nyse l'inizio
legge illuminismo fu un movimento
politico sociale la genesi scusa ma tu
come ti saresti vestita per fare video
lezione quest'oggi è anche se si chiama
didattica a distanza io esigo che vi
comportate e vive stilate a esattamente
come se fossimo a scuola va bene perché
ne vado il nome dell'istituto per io
rappresento era prof sono a casa mia
come dovrei vestirmi scuse come si veste
una signorina non una barbona va bene
adesso fatti subito a cambiare anzi
ashley anzi disconnetti t
non ne voglio più sapere niente di te
per oggi buongiorno raggi di sole al
siamo tutti le braccia e riavviciniamo
alla telecamera così e poi ci
abbracciamo virtualmente non facciamo
facciamo fluire tutta energia mente
cuore cuore e mente t'appartengo se ci
tengo io prometto poi mantengo ecco la
magia della coccole terapia
mi sembra di capire che non mi vedete
bene vero
scopriamo così mi vedete oa no prof bene
anche adesso neanche noi basta ragazzi
mi arrendo tanto l'importante che mi
senta te poi se vedete uno schermo nero
rosso blu non importa tanto sono
buttando sono sicuramente un bel vedere
ecco cosa mangia di buono prof
niente un bottino ma tu continua pure a
leggere avevo finito però ma dov'è
andata
no scusate che mi si è aperto un buco lo
stomaco quasi mancamento io l'ho
assolutamente mancare qualcosa in più
voi continuate abbiamo subito è che
queste elezioni in mezzo la voglio
parlare
insieme a voi della prima guerra
mondiale scusi profumi sono collegata
solo ora
inizio subito tutto da capo molto bene
ragazzi oggi voglio parlare con voi
della prima guerra sto pensando no ma
chi ci ha voglia di fare lezione
una giornata così ricordiamoci un po chi
è chiariamo un po cazzeggiamo un polso
raccontatemi che serie tv state
guardando se ve lo chiedono oggi abbiamo
studiato il preferito perfetto facciamo
le cose fatte da odio prof
evoca dei voti processi storici
industriale di tradate recente neanche
l'intenzione chiara e quello che puntino
a motore che cosa significa che riguarda
lo potete voi per influenzato dal pagare
più piano non si capisce niente
vado più piano non c'è poi le ma dicevo
la quello di capitale in chiave vada
seguita delle come la celerità di getti
quindi acciaio o carbone così non
facilmente e quindi riots prendo il
significato di duramente appunto proprio
si capisce niente deve avere dei
problemi di connessione che ho sentito
bene io ho problemi guardate problemi li
avrete voi lo state attenti durante la
lezione dice tutto qui viene per i
propri cevo che non si sente niente
deficiente
mi avete dato quello che dice tema i
passiti no ragazzi io io no io so tutto
è heavy arrangiate secondo che niente
però non la sentiamo prof
non non la sentiamo prof non si sente
niente
ma come fai a non rendersene conto
scusate devo essermi dimenticato al
libro di lamon venga allora iniziamo su
ho dimenticato pure la pena scusate ma
che squadra che sono l'aspettate vico
arrivo scusate ho un attimino la testa
tra le nuvole mi ricordate dove eravamo
arrivati cena scolapasta che tengono
fame avete sentito a parte voglio avere
chiuso al microfono che non so capire
bene come funziona va bene è stato bello
baci a tutti
ci si vede domani e ciao ciao maronna
mia ma sopratutto un previto faccio
all'amore ma era ancora acceso
avete sentito tutto si prof
scusate una fiction una telenovela come
hai si spegne caro la webcam